i'm 31 i read your book actually when i
was 24. the girls can answer this
question also
so
i met my girlfriend in college
uh you know now i'm 31 have my own
business i make about half a million
dollars a year
and uh
you know
monogamy really doesn't sound like the
best option for me long term
so i guess i'm trying to ask like
should i approach it with my girlfriend
about considering their relationship or
having a
a like a pologonous type of relationship
polygamy pulling
polly you want to get into polly are you
trying to like say you want a maine and
you want other girls is that what you're
saying i hate polly it doesn't work
paulie's not a case that's you remember
you were asking me about like well where
would we go with this marriage stuff
that's one of like the options that
people are throwing out right now it
doesn't work no um
i would say yes
please here we go i would uh so here's
my here's my advice to you is break up
with her like if that's the case then
like don't the the problem that i have
with paulie is not a religious one or a
spiritual one or anything like that it
is because it is impractical
why not simply spin plates why not
simply just have why have a main at all
and just simply play the field until you
until you get to the point like you're
31 yeah and you're making that kind of
money congratulations you're hitting
your stride yeah congratulations you
will hit your stride with your sexual
market value peak will probably be up
yeah 34 to 36 somewhere in there
yeah how old is the girl
sorry
hello
is he gone maybe he's gone yeah yeah
like tom perkins well so
i mean the advice is the same it's it's
it's not that i mean don't pull a
garyvee
i mean because that's what happens when
you say well should i get rid of russia
or not get rid of her
now is the time and do make a clean
break and this is not like an ethical or
a moral thing this is just a practical
thing because if you're if you're
calling in to this show to ask about
that then yeah you you probably need to
just make a clean break and get out
there because you're entering your
sexual market value peak years and
you're in peak selectivity so why not
and you're realizing that now because
you already made a commitment or you
already have some sort of like you're
locked down right now
do yourself a favor and do her the favor
as well don't turn her into gary vee's
wife yeah yeah
please don't do you ladies agree
completely i also think um there's a
difference between polyamory and like an
open more open relationship you don't
necessarily well polyamory you need to
give your your time your dedication and
emotion into multiple people multiple
wives
and if you have your main girl and you
know you're sexually curious and you're
young still then
i you can have a conversation with the
person that you love about what's going
to make you happy and try and compromise
but maybe i'm too idealistic until until
jealousy kick because men and women
handle jealousy i don't think it's
something that needs to define the
relationship i think it's something that
like it's a one-time two-time thing
there's no relationship at that point
there's simply no relationship so that's
why i said maybe i'm idealistic but i
also think that like it's a conversation
you shouldn't be having with us you
shouldn't be having well yeah that too
but i i would say this is that
instead of entertaining these stupid
ideas of maybe i can make it work with
my main chick and have side chicks or
maybe i can do why why even have that
conversation and just like play the
field if you if you're play the field
gentlemen
[Music]
you